Okay, so now that we've talked about Lumen, it's time for us to talk about Lightmass and Lightmaps,
Lightmass being the offline rendering global illumination system as opposed to Lumen's
dynamic global illumination system. So what are we going to cover? What is Lightmass?
The best setting for Lightmass, what the Lightmass importance volume is,
how to create Lightmaps and change in the solver quality. So let's take a look at this.
So what's Lightmass? It's an offline global illumination renderer. It basically costs
virtually zero runtime since it's all pre-baked and pre-calculated,
so you don't have to calculate anything at runtime. The building process does get longer
as your scene becomes more and more complex and Lightmass itself is built using the swarm agent
which allows you to connect multiple PCs if you wanted to, for example, to
build the lighting together. To adjust the Lightmass settings at the actor level,
or you can adjust them globally in the world settings panel. Now this is really important,
Nanite, the high resolution mesh system from Unreal, is made for Lumen and not Lightmass.
So make sure you do turn it off at the project level and that using shadow maps
for the shadow map method. If you don't do this, essentially you could be baking or
crafting forever. So when it comes to the Lightmass and Lightmap settings,
the settings that you want to change to get the best quality inside of the world settings are
the following. So you can change your static lighting level scale to one, the number of
indirect or sky bounces to three between three and ten, so again the higher the number
the better the quality, however the longer the baking time. The indirect lighting quality
to between one and four, and the indirect lighting smoothness between one and one point three.
Make sure you if you want the highest quality disabled compress Lightmaps which improves quality
but decreases the Lightmap size by a factor of four, so that's something to keep in mind.
So when it comes to Lightmass and using it properly, one important feature of this,
or limitation in a way, is the Lightmass importance volume. It's a volume that focuses
the detailed indirect lighting coming from Lightmass, so this will help you reduce your
lighting times because the important calculations will be made only within this volume.
So you can use it to determine an area of importance, you get detailed global
illumination will be restricted in that area based on the settings that you give the
Lightmass importance volume, and any area outside of the importance volume will only get low quality
global illumination or one bounce essentially. When it comes to Lightmap UVs, when you create
a mesh that's going to be lit using the static lighting system in Unreal, you need to
create a Lightmap which is a new UV map that will essentially be used to store, which will
have the lighting texture projected onto it. Why are they important? You need them to create
believable self-shadowing and object cast as shadows, so if I have an object and I receive
a shadow to get good shadows on that mesh you would need a good Lightmap. It can be imported
and the important real thing about Lightmaps is that you need no overlapping UVs,
it needs adequate padding and you need to be able to hide seams.
It can be auto-generated by Unreal and it does actually a really good job
but I think to keep in mind that you are importing them.
So if you take a look at the way the Lightmap UVs actually work is you've got one model and
there's two light sources here. The light is baked onto a Lightmap texture and then you have
the base color texture over that essentially where the Lightmap gets multiplied on top of
the base color texture. So the end result essentially relies entirely on displaying
textures, that's the main important thing. There's nothing actually happening
dynamically here. Now when you're building light, I'm going to take a look at this
ourselves in a second, but when you're building lights it's important to know that there's
different quality settings. Preview will be quick and give you a sort of rough and
dirty approximation of what the lighting might look like and as you go up all the way to
production your baking times will be longer but you'll increase the quality of that
lighting solution as you go up. So let's go ahead and take a look at the next exercise
which will have us creating some lights and baking them into the project. We'll see you there.